now we had a bit of a a different kind
of episode last time we did we it was a
departure i think that's probably good
yeah once in a while maybe i don't know
we'll see if people like it if they if
they do maybe we'll do more of them if
they don't well i think people will come
to these podcasts because they want to
learn something about life and they want
to learn from us uh because they know
how wise
whizzened
we are sure um and they trust uh
anything we say so you know we could do
i think it behooves us and uh the fans
of the podcast to take on a bunch of
different subjects because we could
really educate people through this uh
through this podcast yes you know what i
mean tell me what about last week's
thing i
was like sort of thinking about the
conversation we had and i felt bad about
specifically naming the kid from my high
school
we could beep it out i think maybe we
ought to only because it's like then
that's still then i'm just passing down
the bullying now i have the upper hand
and i'm slamming down the bullying yeah
yeah and bullying only stops when
someone takes the high road um
so you want to take the high road take
the high road we'll go back his last
name i'll leave his first name
his last name great
yeah how are you going to do that with
brandon mcpoyle
can't do it i love brendan mcpoyle okay
brendan mcpoyle is
don't lie he's my buddy man i just like
i feel bad that he was you know
yeah but to me it shouldn't be to me
it's like holy [ __ ] what's up
cat is giant yeah a giant cat i got a
big beautiful cat i love him
i love that cat
what kind of cat is that
it's a badass street cat even though he
looks regal and beautiful wow i'm not a
cat glenn knows i'm not a cat person i
live with him for years with cats and
this is this [ __ ] cat i love this cat
yeah what is it with the smell of cat
[ __ ] being a thousand times worse
than
dog [ __ ] it's not it's just it's in the
house
well maybe that's yeah your dogs aren't
[ __ ] in the house into a litter box
like so you know it smells like the
whole thing this cat doesn't [ __ ] inside
anymore yeah
he only shits outside the cats are brown
now which is the line from this episode
he's a good segway show catcher brown
now
so let's talk about uh
miracle mir what is the title the gang
exploits america gang exploits a miracle
yeah exploits that's good yeah um yeah
yeah what do you guys remember about
this episode i mean i i well first of
all i mean most significantly it's the
introduction of uh rickety cricket
yeah probably right that's probably the
most david hornsby i'm sure we've
discussed him on this podcast already uh
who's a brilliant actor and writer
and really been with us from the
beginning uh he's giving us tons of
funny ideas and and doing a lot of great
writing and he was the first person to
write on the show i mean we we tried to
like
we tried to hire out a couple uh some
people were this episode we did hire two
writers yeah and they did a pass at this
episode and we used a chunk of their
material that's right right right yeah
they were chris romano and eric
right and i believe
maybe i'm
remembering this incorrectly but didn't
they come up with the name rickety
cricket
they might have i think they did i think
they did they might have yeah it's
possible they had a lot of funny ideas
and they were they were good writers and
they were this is the first time we sort
of successfully had someone
uh you know
work with us to write an episode aside
from you know david's contributions yeah
well and hornsby wrote i think the one
that we're going to do next right the
the gang runs for office yeah
that's right i believe he wrote that one
yeah so yeah i had forgotten that uh
chris romano and eric falconer wrote for
us in season two i i thought that the
only other person who wrote for us in
season two was hornsby yeah
yeah yeah that's cool yeah no so uh it's
it's weird though did you guys notice
how like
how grounded uh david's performance is
yes yeah yeah he starts out
he's a really good actor what happened
yeah
yeah he's just leaning too hard lean hat
too heavily into the bits yeah yeah yeah
well we we threw away any ground in this
by the very next usage of his character
i think pretty much banging on the car
which you can
shirtless in the next episode is that
the next time that can't be wow that's a
big jump i think that's the next time we
see him right it's it's in the the the
um the gangster episode or whatever
where he's on the streets and yes you
guys get him doing cocaine and [ __ ] like
that yeah what i noticed about this
episode was that there was like five
story lines all hap like every character
had a distinct and specific storyline
that was separate from the other
characters and they were all they were
all connected obviously in some way but
everybody was sort of off on their own
mac and charlie were together yeah but
each one of them had a different want
and need
and i don't know i i thought that was
interesting in how we took each
individual character and gave them their
own story i didn't notice that yeah
that's tough thing to do with with only
22 minutes to try to have like
you know three or four stories but
usually the smallest story just it's
like a couple of bits i had to cook it
like my thing like my fasting thing yeah
i found that very amusing i found the
the stuff between you and you and me
very music i had some real genuine
laughs that i sort of was in my memory i
remember feeling like yeah this one's
not so great yeah i watched it and
really enjoyed it yeah
um especially the stuff with you and me
and and preaching to those
yeah you got to do you got to do some
really fun stuff like putting on that
big white suit and you know the song do
you guys remember how we came i mean i
i remember us like talking about that
song and like joking about the song but
i remember where exactly i think almost
all of it was improvised
i think i think that whole section of
shoes and the lord giving you shoes oh
that was i don't think any of that was
screaming well i know it was you know
how i know it was improvised because
charlie is
you can see how amused charlie is as
he's coming up with the whole like shoot
that you know trusting god he'll give
you shoes but yeah
he's got a smile you know i was thinking
about that too i was thinking you know
it's funny right like okay you go do
some drama you're not going to be amused
the whole time
but you're you know you get together
you're making comedy
and you you start playing in with an
area and you find it amusing you know
and it's
there's something in that high wire act
of like
obviously we put a lot of hard work and
we take what we do very seriously and
then it's completely not serious to the
point where it's almost okay to just be
laughing while you're doing it
and there's some spark there i don't
know i don't know if i can i wonder if
like subconsciously because i see it in
other shows
right where i'm like oh i think that
person is laughing but i think at the
end of the day maybe even subconsciously
you're like oh they're having fun doing
what they're doing i think so and i
think on a show like this that can be so
like acerbic and aggressive and
difficult like subject material like to
see that we're having fun yeah and that
we're making fun of the people that
we're playing i feel like there's like
there's like this could all fall apart
at any moment kind of a feeling to it
right which is like it's hanging on by a
thread and that's why it's funny yeah
because when you find it if you find
something as you're like as you're
standing on that high wire
you know it's it's it's really
gratifying to know that to just know
that you've hit on something that's like
that's going to strike a chord or at
least that you think is funny yeah yeah
yeah i i remember distinctly that priest
uh spitting directly into my face
[ __ ] disgusting that was oh yeah and
then and then we were we got a little
bit into this yesterday but like how
often we have characters spitting into
each other's faces sure it's a lot yeah
like maybe the most in the history of
any comedy ever right like because
that's not necessarily
funny no no it's it's it's pretty it's
pretty wildly gross and like not you
know it's i mean yeah so the kid spits
in your face in the abortion episode oh
yeah the breeze spits in your face uh
then we have the 1776 episode where like
three or four different people spitting
these guys in the archery space yeah um
what else is there more than that am i
i'm sure
hornsby gets his face
spat on so many times and that's 1776.
yeah he took it like a champ he really
did by the end though he was like
he's like that's enough guys come on
like
like take after take of it too like how
many times did that priest spit in your
face i think one i think that was a one
we got it and uh yeah
that guy was hilarious yeah and i don't
know that he was too far off from the
character he was playing no well i'll
tell you something i looked him up did
you guys look him up he's still alive no
he is not how is he well i mean i i
don't know maybe i looked him up on imdb
maybe they don't know that he's dead but
uh he's
but he was born in 1930 as i recall so
he was he would have been 76 when he
made the episode with us so now oh he
looked bad for 76. yeah
he looked like yeah he's sick
oh my god no i think you know he's no i
i you're wrong actually because he's got
he's like
a theater guy he's like a real like an
acting major
method i he went real yeah
yeah he was i remember him being very
very good um
rhea perlman's father is in that episode
yeah
phil
as the guy who says i think i'd rather
get a blessing from him he looks a
little he looks a lot more religious
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah he seems he seems a lot more
religious there yeah and he was in
cheers
many times right he's like man he's a
recurring
recurring character in characters yeah
yeah he's funny he was great what was he
was he
was he an actor or dude or was he just a
funny guy and they were like let's put
him on cheers because ria's on the show
yes it'll be fun yeah so he's not an
actor at all no
no i think he was like an accountant
that's great or something we should find
out exactly yeah he's [ __ ] great you
know we talk about a lot in this show uh
religion
like a ton
like we all grew up yeah it's because we
all grew up in religious households i
mean you grew up catholic yeah although
you you were you your parents weren't
like
hardcore catholics though right you know
they just were catholic no i went to
every sunday i did all this so they were
yeah okay and and then and obviously you
you're you're well your dad was
pretty religious right yeah it's all
very confusing that well i definitely
grew up catholic went to catholic school
all the way through but did you go to
church every weekend did you go to
church every sunday yeah every sunday
every sunday sunday school uh no we
didn't have to go to sunday school
because we went to monday through friday
school where we got the catholic
beating right into us right right yeah
and i agree and i grew up um methodist
church every sunday sunday school i mean
church was like in in our lives like but
the church we went to in montgomery
alabama was uh i mean it was huge what
it was like it was like a mega church
before there were really a lot of mega
churches you know they even had i think
they had their own show but it wasn't
like it wasn't as big as like the joel
osteen type thing or anything like that
but it was but for the area i mean it
was it was huge and so like the you the
youth group asked they had a youth group
and that whole aspect of it was so fun i
mean we had a
full yeah that's when you went to the
camp what a full-court basketball court
we had like you know all kind of games
and stuff they were always like putting
together activities and stuff you know
so i spent a lot of time
you know i think the major difference
that i see
is like the vast majority from for
better or for worse it seems like more
people
from like that part that like section of
the country that like methodist born
again they truly believe
and i feel like i was just surrounded by
people who didn't but they just go
because that's what their parents did
and their grandparents did and their
parents before that i it didn't there
wasn't a lot of like dialogue really it
was just like this is
part of your identity but it's not
really like something you're
right it's almost actively engaging
the social thing like um
explain this to me
so lots of
battles bloody bloody wars
hatred uh pointing fingers
between you know a protestant and
catholic let's say in ireland uh or just
like a baptist they went a lot further
than pointing fingers yeah yeah yeah
pointing all sorts of things
yeah pointing things that explode uh
that's just it's
it's just [ __ ] bananas it's the same
religion well it's the same god but
you're like well you guys are obsessed
with the virgin mary what is that
right we're not obsessed with that with
her uh over over in the protestants i
mean we like her
you know we recognize her contribution
mm-hmm uh well but like there's a whole
thing i think you hate women more
as a culture than i'm not sure what was
it that is that they have to believe as
a man no no we we only hate women who
try to act like they're equal to men ah
right the women who know their place we
don't hate them we love them we love
them deeply
right so as long as you know your place
you're you're good you're good with the
with the protestants
um but yeah what what's the deal
like what is it about like i i what is
in you guys
that goes back to the the thing with my
with my grandmother how she said she'd
never been with a man in spite of the
fact that her daughter my mother was
there to see her at the nursing home yes
um so she she saw herself in this in
that same way um i did sleep in a bucket
of sperm one night and i believe that's
maybe yeah yeah it's okay it could have
happened that way
[Music]
rob i'll publish this question to you
since you already asked a question
charlie like what is the what are the
pro like what is the things that
separate catholicism from protestantism
like
well i'll tell you right there was a guy
named martin luther and he uh he was all
up in arms about people paying to to go
to heaven and yeah there was i forget
what there was a fancy term for do you
remember the term for those things where
rob it's like uh
yeah i think it's like
it sounds like reparations or something
but it's not that it's
[Music]
but anyway so he's all he's getting
pissed about this and he goes and he and
he and he writes sort of like a list and
he hammers it on a door in a church
somewhere and the list is like no we
don't need to have uh crucifixes in the
church and we don't need all this
ornamentation and we don't need to pay
to go to heaven and
this whole trans substation thing where
the where the cracker actually turns
into jesus nah that can be a metaphor
and you guys are you guys are focusing
on the wrong things let's focus on the
real sort of like uh yeah was the giant
thing is he also like objecting to like
the the sort of the hierarchy the the
whole like
you know just bishops and
cardinals and all these [ __ ]
that are like who are these [ __ ]
people like i can have a direct
relationship with jesus christ it's got
nothing to do with the the catholic
church possibly and i think what sort of
happens people saw that pamphlet and
then there was an uproar
he i think he was probably killed
um i'm not a historian so uh are you not
are you not but but then you know then i
don't know then at some point england
was like actually i think i dig his way
and then there was all sorts of bloody
wars and well well i think that's so
what's interesting about catholic school
is like we didn't really learn we knew
that that guy existed martin luther
right but it was like well he's a
heathen we don't really talk about right
he who shall not believe and we had we
had classes right called religion class
it was called religion and then you
would go you sit there and it would be
catholicism and then even at like 14
you'd be like
well this is a religion right right and
they're like no no this is the religion
and you wouldn't learn about anything
else anything except for roman
catholicism yeah which was very specific
so when you get into like the
nitty-gritty of like other versions of
christianity i have no clue you don't
know no idea other than like talking to
you or talking to charlie i guess i
don't really either because i i only
went to catholic church one time with a
friend of mine and i remember being
i remember all that this is why when we
did that with the the episode where we
were like constantly standing and
kneeling yeah was like i remember
bringing this up to you guys back then
um because the one experience that i had
was like we were constantly standing and
kneeling and everyone knew when to do it
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this
like why are we constantly standing and
kneeling and i didn't get it and then
when they went up to take
uh communion
um they were like
why don't you why don't you just stay
here yes like they didn't let me take
communion right i was like [ __ ] these
people like what you don't give my jesus
cracker no man
you haven't gone through the steps yeah
i i wasn't getting both sorry what are
the steps there's oh yeah
it's an educational thing and then first
is baptism and then there's yeah you
weren't confident you were baptized but
you weren't baptized
no well you're [ __ ]
oh you're gonna go to hell no matter
what yeah
well if there is a hell unless that's a
very deathbed
you have enough time to be like my bad
jesus christ my lord and savior yeah
basically and then you're good yeah yeah
now i got both i went to both catholic
my dad went to a catholic church in town
and my mom was right
that her mother and my guest father went
too why uh so every now and then
i got to go dabble in in
the protestant thing too
i didn't care for it though it was a lot
more kind of hippie-dippy oh you like
your [ __ ] oh that's so
no i like my [ __ ] like don't bother me
let me come in and do the kneeling
standing eat the cracker get out of here
yeah i don't know
that was what we saw a lot of romance
yeah it was like hey you just show up
you go to the shortest mass whatever
like we know there's a priest that does
like a 25-minute mass that's the one you
do yeah you get in you get out
everybody's happy yeah i don't want to
do the whole like
bake sale and then we're going to be
holding hands and singing well method is
such a it's a it's a light it is a
lifestyle it is
it is great in that because that's the
whole community aspect that's right and
that's the thing that's like i think
that
is strange and difficult and we've
talked about this a little bit already
but it's probably the reason why it
keeps coming back up on the show is that
it's very confusing for me personally
because the catholic church has also
done amazing things for the world and
for me personally yeah like my schooling
my education
going through jesuit i've talked about
this like quite a bit but like my jesuit
education is like truly who made me
who i am today so it's really i have
this like very odd relationship with
them yeah it's a tricky thing right
because
like you said
tons of good all around the world done
all the time and tons of bad and tons of
people taking advantage of it and
twisting it and and also the fact that
it it sort of
it needs to feed the beast like any
other religion or
cult you know or it was like no we need
more people we need more money like
it's tricky yeah it's tricky yeah and so
i
i remember at the time there was a whole
and it continues to this day but there
were there was like a year where people
were seeing the virgin mary
oh yeah yeah all over the place there's
like a virgin mary and a piece of toast
at one point yeah like yeah
i had any visions like ghosts or like
anything anything of the spiritual realm
that you feel like i had a i had a
really crazy experience once in my
apartment in new york um that
scared me beyond belief hmm go
go okay so so i was
asleep or half a sling that's sort of
like half asleep no no i was just i was
what do i i was asleep and
but in my dream i could see myself in my
bed asleep
and there was this dark amorphous
thing floating through the air floating
in and it floated into my room and i
could watch it but i couldn't and i was
just trying to wake up
because i knew i was asleep
but i couldn't
wake up and and i was like frozen it's
one of those things where you're like
paralyzed in your sleep
and it just
and it was getting closer and as it got
closer there was this
like humming noise it was like
i mean it was freaky as [ __ ] and then it
was just
hovering directly over me just like just
like [ __ ] this dark dark dark energy
or whatever the [ __ ] it was and then i
remember i was finally able to open my
eyes and when i opened my eyes it was
still there and then it it the sound
went
and like it like dissipated and went
away but like when i [ __ ] opened my
eyes it was still there
it i mean again probably all in my head
but still it was
it was one of those
it is the scariest thing that i've ever
experienced in my entire life i don't
know what the hell was going on there it
was an old building they they tore it
down were you mildly aroused as well i
mean
it could have been the night man yeah it
could have been like the night because
yeah there's a ghostbusters situation
there where dan aykroyd's sleeping and
then all of a sudden the ghost hovers
over him
then suddenly his
his pants unbuckle i was watching that
with my son
when he was much too young to under well
he's still too young
and we get to that scene he goes
daddy what's happening yeah
and you know dan akroy is getting a
[ __ ] from the ghost and i go
uh russell he's
he's chasing ghosts so much that he's
that he's having dreams they're getting
him dressed for school
oh yeah that checks out
he's like cause i thought he would get a
blow job dad but all right okay you said
he's getting dressed but yeah he seems
way too happy he sure is enjoying
getting dressed for school i just had to
deal with this last week because i
we should talk we could do a whole
podcast on introducing the show our show
to our kids but but i took leo to the
mix
and and that's an audio mix and i
thought i know it's gonna be fun go see
what dad does and i didn't even look at
the episode but in the episode i won't
give anything away because we've done
this a million times dennis is betting a
woman and we have a very specific shot
like straining as he's how'd that go
yeah and he just turned to me and was
like in the mix he's like what is that
and i was like he's doing push-ups and
dennis do you see how dennis has like
glenn's got a great body thank you and
we have to justify it by making dennis
do exercises you have to justify it
and he was like oh let me ask you
questions
how how old how
why is there whine
old enough for him to be like
yeah there's a woman screaming something
else
at one point it's probably most people
listening are like uh yeah it's like
three years ago do you do you like
explain sex and be like well they're
i've already been teaching the
conversation with axel who's 11. i think
they're i mean they they start teaching
sex ed yeah at our the school that uh
mine and rob's kids go to yeah at a
pretty early age i mean they they're
breaking they're breaking the ice yeah
yeah but but i've had but i've had the
sit down like let's talk about it what
is the church's stance on sex these days
is it still hey just don't do it
um is that
are they still furious if you use a
condom or have they like that that's a
catholic thing that's a catholic thing
right it was right it was like
absolutely
i still believe that birth control is
problematic for them yeah
as is abortion
and that was always the rub
okay i won't touch abortion yet but
let's just start with birth control
how are you gonna have a problem with
that i just
because because sex is solely for his
creation yes for professionals
and you can and
enjoying it is a byproduct
but is but it is something that is
blessed by god this is for god
not for you right two of you to enjoy
but also like the catholic church wants
you to make more little catholics you
know what i mean
they they want more of of them you know
it makes the cult strong imagine that
that information's first getting out to
people where it was like
we will love each other like our
brothers
only the poor and the meek shall inherit
the earth
a sex is really bad and we won't do
anymore
wait wait wait are you sure
wait wait wait wait
yes quite sure
oh sex uh yes what about anal sex
very bad very bad we're going to destroy
a whole city where they're doing that
nonstop
still not good not good not great not
great masturbation no no masturbation
none of this
well i do know yeah masturbation is
problematic because you're taking the
seed and you're and you're killing the
the seed
thing like your seed was not supposed to
touch the ground right if it hit the
oh boy yeah yeah yeah my seed never
touches the ground i try to avoid
letting it touch the ground to this day
[Laughter]
or a stream
that may have been the only time where
women felt pretty good to be excluded
from the conversation all together
because it was like well i guess we can
just keep doing it they're not even
mentioning us because we don't even
matter enough we just didn't let
ourselves stupid yeah because they're
not even yeah absolutely yeah that's fun
well speaking of man women are your
property
damn so close yeah okay well i like that
one well that works but i can't have sex
with them no
well you can but they gotta get pregnant
but you don't make babies yeah then the
women are like god yeah well i'll tell
you guys uh something that uh on the
surface is sexual but uh you know it it
really isn't sexual it's just about uh
you know humiliation and comedy and
that's putting someone's balls oh
on uh
on someone else's chin okay let's talk
about that or
so
the the network we originally in the
script it was uh that we teabagged him
right because
uh for those of you who aren't familiar
with that expression if you're listening
to the podcast you probably are
uh tea bagging is where you dip your
balls into someone's mouth uh as one
would a tea bag an unconscious person
uh and by the way
this episode's unconscious but you could
teabag a conscious person i'm perfectly
sure you could have if there were that
was a sexual willingness
each other
yes that's fine
that's fine as long as it's only for
comedy if it's done for coming purposes
thank you
both of my kids have asked me what
teabagging is because that's a popular a
video game there's a video game out
there that where they're teabagging each
other i'm sorry
what game are you letting your kids play
uh fortnight oh dude so you should get
them off that crap what are you doing
and for why they don't play it anymore
but there was a period two years ago
their classmates and yeah they teabagged
each other when there's a dead body they
like basically crouch over it and they
call it tea bagging and so i had to
explain what that is and
you know this megan and i were talking
about this yesterday like this is where
there's this
very specific um and dangerous gray line
that is very specific to men
and not and does not cross over into
women where it is theoretically funny to
have a friend who's asleep and you put
your
dick or balls onto his head or face
because he might wake up
no i would never do this to glenn for
example you got to know the audience
because he's not going to find it funny
i don't think charlie would either but i
know many guys especially when i was 15
16 you know 17
what if that happened to you you didn't
feel violated you didn't feel assaulted
right because that's sexual assault yeah
i mean legitimately sexual sexual
assault
i think about like what happens if
megan's passed out right now and we're
like true so you pass out and i put but
that's the point i'm trying to make
and we take a picture that's the point
i'm trying to make that's just hilarious
that's the point i'm trying to make
which is that there is a difference
between doing that to but you still have
to recognize that it's a willing
participant meaning it's your buddy yeah
and he's going to wake up and be like oh
they got me now i i can like get him no
but it can't be some stranger that
you're doing it to you're sticking your
genitals
what if he what if it was there was
something called called plumbing you
know it was like to plum someone and
yeah and you
enter their you know anus while they're
asleep sure you know uh it's the same
for the same thing for comedy it's not
sexual it's funny it's funny
you got plenty i will say
it is a bizarre thing to actually do
like talking about it in a vacuum is one
thing but like i would
i would never be like hey this is gonna
be really funny when i put my genitalia
into this guy's mouth
no but i i don't think we i ever even
did that in high school i never saw
anyone do it the closest thing the
closest thing i can think is like we had
a thing where
if you were sitting and your back was to
people like every once in a while you'd
look over and there was a dick on your
shoulder a dick or
like a ball dick and balls that's pretty
shoulder yeah and we would never ever
even at 16 we would never do that to
like one of our girlfriends or a woman
because we knew that that was even a 15
16 that that was inappropriate but for
dudes like every once in a while you'd
just be sitting there and you'd feel
something and you knew you could feel a
presence behind you and then you knew
that you knew it was there and then you
had to get it you had to slap it as fast
as you could before the guy
knew that it was coming
that's a good that's a good comeback to
that right to slap penis you're gonna
and that's why the balls stopped coming
so right the penis you catch a penis
with it with okay that you can get it's
gonna sting but it's not gonna
the whole nut sack that's painful very
painful yeah that's um no me my buddies
were not doing that to each other no
yeah we weren't doing that either we
don't do that in the south i mean like
so that was just like a feeling that's
like that was just yeah you and your
homo erotic friends um
i mean sometimes you know like a good
mother draw a good mustache on somebody
it's a sharpie that's kind of gag yeah
but we have different kinds of friends
actually sure yeah well i i but i want
to say so i do want to talk about this
because i i remember us finding this so
perplexing the the network would not let
us say tea bagging on the show
so we so
we submitted balls to the chin
to them and they were like yeah that's
fine yeah
that's a strange thing like
so strange who writes the rules i guess
the idea is maybe one's less offensive
because you haven't entered the person's
mouth technically you've just put your
balls on their chin
and that's like slightly less offensive
somehow i don't know now i think if we
wanted to put tea bagging in the show
they would give a [ __ ] yes they would
definitely let us put it now it is crazy
as a society
how and this must go back to like a
puritanical thing just from the roots of
the country but like
you know because we were escaping
uh religion and
for stricter religion we were coming
here to be like no we want to be more
strict about religion
and
why i mean
like our most popular movies are
extraordinarily violent with people
getting shot and blown up
and like if you saw someone's
penis
like that's that's way too far that's
taking things too far
what
that's crazy right why how did we
how do we come to this
no i'd rather maybe see violence in a
movie than a bunch of dicks but
but not but not everybody lots of people
would rather see dicks than violence but
it depends on the movie it's the best in
the movie right so there are there is a
type of movie
there's a type of movie that you would
like to watch that has dicks just
how are you going to give me a magic mic
without the dicks you know what i mean
like right right that doesn't feel very
bad i enjoy looking at a dick i i like
it i don't have a problem i don't
probably look at anything yeah
okay
great well we've stopped
that's great guys that's great well i'm
just saying it doesn't seem right it
seems like uh you know religion got in
the way of uh us viewing dicks
especially dicks for comedy
oh yeah yeah yeah dicks and comedies
that's definitely funny yeah it used to
be that male nudity
immediately
elicited a uh at x rating rated x yeah
and now i believe finally that's been
eradicated but but an erect male penis i
think might still get you might still
get you that at that axe right which i
what's
i don't get it well it's the it's the
you know the state of ecstasy that the
man is either in or not in that
determines the rating
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i guess it's to keep
our it's for the same reason why we're
like dancing around the topic with our
kids you know it's like we got to put an
x on this so no kids stumble into seeing
these penises and vaginas yeah
i don't know i i feel like the rules
were made up by men at a certain point
certainly like the mpaa it was just a
group of dudes who were like
it's okay to see women make it like we
can exploit women that's fine that's
that's no problem
vaginas though like i think that would
be true yes you can that would get you
an x-ray really [ __ ] way the entire
80s yeah the entire 80s it was like you
you it was just
bush after bushes
you're not seeing the vagina itself
right you're like
do you mean if someone's
taking the hair and splitting it
together yeah just the same way that if
a guy was running around nothing but a
giant bush
and you couldn't see the guy's penis
they'd probably be like yeah okay that's
funny
you know but if you even a little bit of
penis peeks out of that that bush there
we're good you know yeah we gotta slap a
new rating
[Music]
well what else about this episode i mean
uh i know we've talked about my my weird
uh
oh yeah oh that's a great stunt that's a
great style yeah you fainted off that
but you fainted off that bar stool you
look you you yeah that's some that's
some stagecraft yeah uh i don't know i
think uh just that that's sort of like a
younger man's
younger man's game you know what i mean
like if i was asked to do that now i'd
be like damn that's gonna really hurt
like but i think back then i was like oh
yeah i can do that that'd be fun like i
i thought i thought it would be fun and
it was i don't know it did look real
though mike yeah
the truck right is to to not have to not
like put your hands out like that was
the tricky thing about it i remember but
i don't know i don't know
like i hurt my shoulder man i don't know
i slept on it weird or something
my right shoulder's [ __ ] up and that's
just from sleeping on it imagine what
would happen if i fell off a bar stool
now yeah oh god in heaven
everything just hurts more these days
guys you know yeah i'm all banged up
god damn podcast brought to you but
you're fine you're fighting you
attribute it to the uh ice baths that
you take i attribute i have no real
chronic
physical issues i think i have good
genetics my dad doesn't really
and and also i don't know
never being an athlete
ever like you now you're starting down a
specific joint you spent years and years
and years wearing down very specific
joints doing all that even if it was in
your youth like yeah you know and for 10
12 i never did any of that
i also find that almost every acting
thing that i do whether it's on sunny
or
any other projects i've gotten to do
i'm going through a lot of like
slamming into things and right you know
just like it's very physical
yeah
yeah when it comes to like the physical
comedy stuff where you have to really
like you could and that [ __ ] really like
i think people think
like there is a way to do all those
things all those stunts and things like
quote unquote safely but that doesn't
mean you're not getting hurt you are
getting [ __ ] hurt you're just not
like breaking a bone ideally or you know
something worse than that but like
you know when a when you fall off of
something or get slammed into a wall
it [ __ ] hurts yeah [ __ ] hurts you
get bruised up you get beat up i mean
when we did fist fight you know i'm not
playing a guy who's supposed to look
like rocky balboa in his prime right i'm
not i'm playing the nerdy guy who
doesn't want to be in the fight and
so obviously i'm not like ripped in an
amazing fighting shape and we shot that
fight for
like a week straight so you're doing
like hour days all day every day just
just you know an ice cube is not a stunt
man so sometimes when he goes to throw
you into a school bus he overshoots it
and you go slamming into the school bus
you know and i got sciatica on that like
i couldn't feel my foot it was crazy
i can remember
like
so i'm watching a lot of football now
soccer in the us and i'm so used to
watching it on tv and it looks like the
guys are always flopping and they're
like oh man get the [ __ ] up they're all
faking it when you go and see it live in
person like on the field you see how
hard they're smashing into each other oh
it's brutal it's brutal and so i was
asking them about like what does it feel
like when somebody's like you know
you're running at each other and i've
heard this from a lot of professional
athletes they say you know the big hits
aren't the big things it's like the
small things you weren't expecting and i
remember the biggest i think the worst
injury you ever had charlie
[Music]
yeah was that time well no you didn't
break it you bruised it right you landed
on your elbow i got like a hairline
fracture in it and and bruises and yeah
and like i remember it it was lingering
for like eight months because i remember
the doctors were like it almost would
have been better if you cracked it
completely yeah
otherwise it couldn't heal and i
remember you were in pain for like for a
long time little nagging things yeah
that was from that was from the uh the
snow blower in the christmas episode and
that was just you just
yeah you just jumped into the air and
you just have to know that i missed the
phone so there was a fall map but there
was so much like snow blowing couldn't
really get a sense so i jumped as high
as i could in the air curled my back
into the ball and then just came right
down on the ground
and then and then i was like oh that
hurt but the shot was still going so i
did it again and i missed
again
and i went to the hospital like i think
a few hours later and danny went with me
being like i don't i'll help you like
get in i think i mentioned this
i can't get you in you're like i get you
i'll get you the door i'll get you
the nurse didn't know who danny devito
was no we talked about this on the
podcast we did we did no we didn't
yes we did we just talked about it yes
we did
we talked about this on the podcast not
when i was here okay meg
okay megan says no and she's literally
she's edited the episodes i'm telling
you right now we did not i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking were we in
the editing room talking about it i
think we're talking about vodka
definitely definitely definitely 100 did
not talk about it in the podcast it was
under the it was the conversation we
were having was whether or not people
like knew the show and how weird it was
the people like it has been on for 15
years and people were like what's that
i've heard that and then you told the
story about danny but maybe it was just
the two of us it might it might have
been a problem you know it might have
been let me ask you guys this did you
eat breakfast today no yes
i've been doing it twice you guys
haven't eaten today no i haven't this is
i haven't i haven't eaten i've been in
two years i normally would have but we
didn't go to the office and then i was
in the car it was weird times i usually
eat around like 11 30 so i'm gonna i'm
gonna overshoot that but uh but i could
i cannot eat till
noon one o'clock something like that i
got here a little bit early because i
just went straight from dropping my kid
to school over and then
i was like oh maybe i'll just find like
a little restaurant near you but there's
so much traffic around your house that i
was like i'm just gonna go park on the
street and
do some calls and emails and things but
i should have i should have gone to a
little restaurant i should go to
in-n-out burger and uh it's it's very
similar
what should go to in and out first we
should go for lunch see if anybody's
see if anything's popping off over there
we are sitting on a miniature set of
paddy's pub i should bring this up i i
think it's maybe like so uh it was in
our office and we got rid of that office
and you and they were like what do you
want to do with it and rob you said oh
i'll take it i'll put it up in my in my
home and my in my uh whatever you want
to call this little side office
why did we build this
i have did we just build it for fun yeah
yeah we just it was we were dead we we
got those offices we knew they were
going to be year-round offices we were
gonna we were under a deal and we were
like let's make it nice you know we put
a little yeah we put like a little i
think we were also like you you'd see
like images you'd see like the south
park offices or like the simpsons
offices or like any like long-running
comedy show and they were always like
cool ping pong tables and putting greens
and like all this cool fun [ __ ] you know
what i mean and we were like we should
do that and so we put in like a little
we put it a little bit yeah i think we
didn't use any of it ping pong table we
use the ping pong table i feel like that
structure never had that energy though
but probably only because there wasn't
enough space to really like run the show
from there probably probably if we had
set that up in a larger space where we
were actually right running the show
from then it will have the hustle bustle
i think you're right you know of an
office but instead it was just like this
strange little miniature set yeah in
this little we which we never use
because by that point we're all married
with kids and so we didn't have like we
never sat at the bar and had drinks no
no not at all
no we've never really been we've
we've really just been kind of people
that work together and then when we
leave maybe we'll go out we used to go
out together but we would never like
drink at work i think we definitely
talked about this too like every once in
a while on set we would but we never
like drinking right how many people no
no i mean we're doing a job yeah that's
that's a common misconception that we
should clear up right because i that's a
weird thing with like oh you guys
probably just get high as [ __ ] and like
right episode i'm like i'm sorry no
we so don't we so don't like
i mean there are people who do yeah i
know
can be high as [ __ ] all day long and
write like amazing stuff and i could
there's no way i could do that no way
yeah i couldn't no but
you haven't built up the tolerance i
think that takes a lot of practice i
also think i i mean we just
i think any drug just affects everybody
differently right because i mean there's
no way that he feels the way i feel when
i'm high yeah because if he felt the way
i felt when he wouldn't yeah he wouldn't
do it he wouldn't do it he wouldn't do
it i i've tried every single kind of
[ __ ] strand just smoked it i've
gummied it i've everything yeah it
definitely
um yes you can put weed up your butt
still very good
[Applause]